theo nick
arie
question for you you're tricking off
what was it like living in ecuador this
year
and
did you happen to eat any kui aka guinea
pig this guy's latino the way he said is
it
gang gang go lakers
[ __ ] you dude [ __ ] the lakers that
wasn't a real championship you [ __ ] how
dare oh my god you [ __ ] spraying it
on me all right first of all i'll let
you apologize for making fun of the
[ __ ] uh heads chin scarf before i
realize what you were doing now you were
trying to hurt me and it worked bro and
it worked
did you think he was being hurtful there
i felt like he was being kind of like
jabby hurtful fun really
yeah but i think
another way he cares he wanted to send
in a question he did care yeah yeah and
he's not being mean i i feel like a lot
are a lot of lakers fans for giving to
you if you if have anybody well
generally laker fans are dumb they're
like not an intelligent species you know
really yeah yeah yeah you'll see them
with their with their the flags all the
time but then when they're bad they took
the flags off because they don't really
support the team you know they're just
kind of morons who need something to
believe in yeah because they don't have
good lives good jobs good families
their lives are ugly generally and um
and so it takes some making up you know
um so they lash out but uh but this guy
seemed cool i don't know
so they lash out that's a great question
though and that's really what it's based
on is that man do you have any i did
have koi a bunch of times it's guinea
pig it's in the andes in ecuadorian
andes and i think maybe peruvian um so i
went for covet 2 i went to ecuador for
six months yeah i just [ __ ] same as
you but like i went somewhere else
did you um
what were some things that were real
nice about being out there first of all
well
well the cool the guinea pig was so
[ __ ] it was like duck it was so
[ __ ] good
and i mean you'd have it at truck stops
you'd have it at nice restaurants it was
but it's just this whole thing splayed
out like this
and they leave their teeth on oh yeah
and but i mean i would just destroy it
really yeah i wanted to put it in a
chili or something or chili no you can
but does you put a spit in it and then
it just like turns and it's just like
straight through his ass through his
mouth oh dude yeah i used to sell him
growing up that's what that [ __ ] is
harrowing i know that's one of the
reasons why yes too oh it was so [ __ ]
good but there's other [ __ ] too not
putting anything in their butt like that
i guess when they're deceased probably
they do it huh
yeah they're already dead because we saw
a bunch of them like like kind of
skinned but the skin is so hard man it
was so good and what are they doing with
the furs is there is are you seeing
things that they're doing with the furs
no i didn't but they probably sell them
or something or make like
[ __ ] out of it like they're poor there
so
they yeah can you look up kui fur for us
yeah i don't know
um but it was just being away from the
american news
was that really nice i didn't find out
who won the election for like
three weeks four weeks
i it was illegal we never found out yeah
i didn't know that i would be like i
feel like to jazz i hate talking to the
election he goes well it's nobody and
i'm like oh really like i was still
figuring it out yes um yeah yeah yeah
yeah oh that's it top left
it's so [ __ ] it's so [ __ ] put
under a melon or something put whatever
you want under oh that's uh that's um
it's these cheese things um it's like
cheese potato things i forget what
they're called now how was the food down
there this is um
so fresh
so delicious so this is a delicacy cooy
so this is a wealthy man's treat it's
like 20 bucks 25 bucks
so that's what breaks my heart then what
yeah yeah yeah not everything but but
like truck stop people could have it you
could do a quarter you know
but not every day although some people
like just caught their own they're
everywhere
anthony bourdain was like well he went
down i didn't see it but i heard he did
a
episode there and he was like this could
solve world hunger man
just get over the [ __ ] second grade
[ __ ] when you saw them when they were
cute it'd be great yeah that's the part
i think is the tough part cause they're
really they're almost like a pony just
really compromised into a really small
space what i got lucky in is is um like
a ground pony first i had one and then i
went to uh the equator goes through
there they have this little set up and
they're really good about education
about all the different indigenous
people there and all the different uh
parts of their country and the galapagos
so the amazon to the mountains and
different just tribes and stuff and so
in this exhibit they had a bunch of
guinea pigs um and they were like this
is a part of the andean um tradition and
stuff like that but i already eaten it
but man those guinea pigs are so [ __ ]
cute that i don't know if i could have
after i saw those guinea pigs uh they're
so beautiful man i mean that's the thing
that that's one thing i think that's
real fascinating about them and a lot of
where i'm from they use them to teach
you about your grandparents a lot of
people they if your grandparents getting
sick your family gets you a guinea pig
and then the guinea pig dies and that's
how you learn about that another
grandparent's like oh that's gonna
happen to me yeah what or the parents
will say this is gonna happen to grandpa
you know oh to the kids yeah it's like a
this is a little gateway to death a
little stair step can you google in on
the cute one can you just look at that
cute picture of them
there we go i wonder if that's
i mean that look at that
oh punil peru
i mean look at the delicacy yeah it's
now what's this what's the meatiest part
that backstrap that rump
underneath the belly oh
yeah the the skin is so hard so it
really dreams too where it keeps its
thoughts yeah i could have a family i'm
in a giddy family you're like yay
[Laughter]
oh this one like tribal music what if
you ate that you ate it and you knew
what they liked you know wouldn't that
be crazy
yeah i would like if you really want to
go delicacy you find their family keep
them alive while they like let them
watch you eat yeah they're dead
the provider
and that right there is already fear
that is a perfect example of ari shavir
of going to a level that you would put
one under a bright lamp
he's sitting there
tape his eyelids open good
dad no
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two
options watch one this one or this one
you